all that matters is the now and what got
us to this point
[Music]
stay with me sir stay with me
where's your mom or dad
i don't know i can't leave you here
i'll walk you to the elk
i think this thing is really happening
[Music]
you can see it out there
[Music]
could i have your attention please
we have shelter we have food
this is the best thing that could have
possibly happened
[Music]
we're the traveling
symphony we travel for a reason just try
to make the world make sense for a
minute
no one finds people from before
sometimes i think we should be out there
looking for them
i come to you with an invitation
to the museum of civilization
[Music]
what happened to you in the first 100
i was lucky he had grown up and cared
about me
welcome to the museum
of civilization
before
it's coming back
i won't let it
we have to abandon the future
all that matters is the now and what got
us to this point
and we're in this together
and we're a family now
[Music]
so
how many people have we seen now
plow guy the two bandana meth guys
the lady with no eyes
a lady with no eyes
you